hi I'm Erik Bosse and then amused into
our hearts with an entertaining mostly
understandable Tom Hardy who kicks
family-friendly ass even in the
cinematic universe without spider-man
how did they do it this movie is filled
with interesting design choices and
subtle references to the venom comics
and deeper parallel suit numbers
cinematic influences so I'm gonna break
it all down as we've rewatched this
movie scene my scene it's where the
warning in case you haven't seen venom
yet what you doin here let's get started
okay venom opens in space with a crash
landing of a light foundation space
shuttle now Venom's classic origin in
the comics is he's an alien symbiote
that latches on to spider-man when he's
off Earth so that when he returns he
gets his new cool black suit that makes
Peter Parker a little too aggressive and
impulsive so he detaches the symbiote
and accidentally passes it on to his
rival at the Daily Bugle Eddie Brock
that's how venom traditionally still
possesses some of these spider-man DNA
that's why he kind of resembles him and
possesses an inky version of Peters web
powers and has that white spider logo on
his chest but as I said before this
venom movie origin story bypasses a
spider-man stat
see Sony produced this movie and
technically owns the film rights to
spider-man as well but currently they're
Tom Hollands spider-man is being
co-produced with Marvel in the MCU
whereas this venom movie is separate
from Marvel Cinematic Universe so this
venom has no white spider logo in the
chest and its powers are less spider-man
II than they are I guess hokey but we do
get one Marvel Easter Egg right away in
this scene the surviving astronaut
piloting the shuttle is named Jameson
which is a nod to John Jameson the
astronauts son of J jonah Jameson
they're actually versions of the venom
comics where his Space Shuttle is the
one that brings this avea to Earth by
the way some have seen some similarity
between this movies opening in the 2017
movie life which features an alien
specimen outbreak on a space shuttle
that's orbiting earth but now venom is
not a sequel to life some people are
saying the trailers shared some stock
footage but guys it's just a case of
Hollywood sticking to some familiar
concepts let's not confuse incompetence
with conspiracy anyway this space
expedition was funded by Carlton Drake
Riz Ahmed
of the light foundation Drake and a
light foundation are from the Marvel
comics as well it's a shadowy cabal
survivalists who planned for Earth's
future after nuclear holocaust though
here ahmed's Drake is more of a Elon
Musk type technology environmentalists
Titan of industry
this venom movie was largely based on
the venom lethal protector comics which
relocate Eddie Brock from a villain in
New York to an antihero in San Francisco
fighting against the light foundations
five spin-off symbiotes riot phage
scream agony in Lasher now only riot
gets named in this movie though
apparently this EMT was credited as
Donna in the comics the symbiote scream
attaches to the woman Donna Diego moving
on to Eddie Brock Tom Hardy now Hardy is
definitely a disciplined physical actor
who never backs down from a big
character choice big for you in this
case II based Eddie Brock on Woody Allen
what he described as the filmmakers
tortured neurosis and humor though I
assume not the creepily sleeping with
your adopted stepdaughter apart he also
looked at UFC fighter Conor McGregor for
McGregor's taste and capability for uber
violence and the rapper Redman whom he
described as out of control and living
rent-free in his head his fiance is and
Wayne Michele Williams and as a lawyer
in Eddie's wife turned ex wife in the
comics as well more on her later Eddie
gets assigned to interview Drake and we
see that he's a clover Porter hosting
video news segment so look a lot like
vice news guys most reporters are not
that cool and over dinner he and Anne
allude to an incident that led to him
moving out to San Francisco this could
be a nod to Eddie's back story in the
comics see there's a villain named Cindy
tur and Eddie interviewed with someone
he thought was a Sin Eater he confessed
all the crimes but the in spider-man
caught the real Sin Eater and basically
exposed
Eddie scoop as false it forced him to
resign his newspaper in disgrace we also
learn he's seen that and works for a law
firm called Michelin Ian MacFarlane
which is actually a reference to david
michelinie and Todd McFarlane comic
artists who created the venom character
in the late 80s Eddy uses and
confidential legal records to blow up
his interview with Drake getting himself
fired and dumped now his new apartment
is in the Shuler building which is an
easter egg nod to Randy Schuler that's
the name of the child fan who wrote a
letter to Marvel Comics in the 80s
requesting for spider-man to have a new
black suit and Marvel actually bought
the idea awesome with a check for $220
and a proceed to make big-time Q money
with the property while looking for new
work Eddie calls a man named Barney
Bushkin that's another Marvel reference
he's the editor of The Daily Globe a
rival newspaper to Jay jonah Jameson's
Daily Bugle meanwhile Drake and his
light foundation enablers
human testing with the symbiotes by his
side is Doris Cerf Jenny slate and this
poor volunteers name is Isaac which
Drake realizes is also the name of an
Old Testament figure whose father
Abraham nearly sacrificed him to show
his faith to God but if you listen to
Carlton Drake throughout this movie he
clearly has some more blasphemous
beliefs basically he views himself as an
Old Testament God willing to go through
with acts of Wrath later he actually
describes humans as such poor design
this movie was directed by Ruben
Fleischer who has directed some great
horror comedies like zombie land at
Santa Clarita diet he cited directors
like John Carpenter David Cronenberg as
influences for this movie and then the
scene you can definitely see their
voices in this horror imagery carpenter
directed the thing which has a similar
frightening alien specimen taking over
humans and mutilating their bodies and
Cronenberg is really the master of
practical body horror and movies like
the fly in which Jeff Goldblum plays a
scientist who kind of like Drake aims to
fuse two species but ends up turning
himself into a freak of nature
now these symbiotes were created with
CGI and the VFX supervisor said that
they based their look on the organic
movement of sea creatures in scientific
demonstrations of unusual non-newtonian
fluids the inhumanity of this experiment
leads Dora to whistle blow to Eddy and
she mentions she once believed Drake was
curing cancer is actually another nod to
the comics and the Ultimate Comics venom
also kind of began as an attempt to cure
cancer this eventually leads to Eddie
and Doris sneaking into the lab at night
where Dora gives Eddie the lowdown
explaining that the light foundation
found the symbiotes which of course was
corrected from the symbiote to
pronunciation in the trailer on a comet
and we later learned that there's a
whole race of these things which is
adapted from the other major comic
influence on this movie Planet of the
symbiotes the simulates are actually a
race called the Clint R of which venom
was kind of a loser for wanting to bond
with the toast instead of consume it
Eddie's snooping leads to him getting
contaminated by Maria his homeless
friend turned test subject he escapes in
the woods and returns home where this
movie finally becomes venom Tom Hardy as
an actor gets to show off his jekyll and
hyde aspect of the character and we hear
Venom's voice for the first time it
actually was also recorded by Hardy he
apparently cited singer James Brown as
an influence on the voice nope I don't
really hear that there any goofs off
around town and he gets to know his new
copilot he learns that venom prefers
living flesh spud he'll settle for tater
tots and chocolate
the comics actually explain that venom
eats human heads because he needs fennel
philomene which is a chemical that
stimulates the human brain the clinched
our species requires this chemical but
it's also found in chocolate Eddy
returns to his place where he runs into
Drake's head of security and this guy's
name is Roland trees which is another
name for the comics creases another
member of the life foundation Fleischer
actually did a director breakdown of
this fight for Vanity Fair they should
check out but as we watch it you can
really see how Tom Hardy makes Eddie
Brock looks so puppeteered he reacts to
his limbs in real time as they operate
out of his control
actually his movement is a reference to
Steve Martin in the movie all of me when
Lily Tomlin is in his head fighting with
him for control of his body actually if
you look really closely at Hardy's ear
you can almost see a hidden earpiece
that he wore so that he could listen to
his own venom audio that he recorded
before and then react to them as he's
listening to the voice inside his head
in real time also during the scene you
could finally hear the venom music score
with these deep synthesized bass notes
to emphasize the symbiotes emergence
[Music]
this movie was composed by Ludwig
Johnson who is the same guy who composed
Black Panther there's actually another
black panther easter egg in the scene
one of the guards here was the same
stunt actor who did all of chadwick
boseman stunts in black panther this
leads to the exciting motorcycle chase
to the streets of San Francisco ending
with venom healing Eddie's broken limbs
and fully overtaking his body now the
VFX here is pretty impressive
notice how Venom's mouth appears to
swallow Eddie's head the way a snake
would swallow its prey both literally
and holistically consuming Eddie Brock
concept artist Paolo Jindo so sighted
natural predators like sharks and snakes
in the way that their drool looks as a
swallow as reference points for this
design meanwhile the VFX supervisor
discuss the difficulty in animating
Venom's tongue because you know it
really needs to be twisted in crazy
shapes to look like the character of
venom but also remember the tongue is
necessary in the way that the mouth
looks as words are formed so the
animators got around this by studying
actors like Clint Eastwood and Jack
Palance
known for delivering their dialogue
through clenched teeth that way the
tongue could be more flexible with the
animation somos notice Venom's dialogue
here
that line is actually a direct quote
from venom in the comics The Amazing
Spiderman issued 374 Eddie insists on
getting his discriminating photos to his
former editor so he invent him climbs
San Francisco's transamerica pyramid
kinda like King Kong but in this case
the plane really does rattle the Beast
presumably from the sound waves of the
jet engines eddie later tells an that
the symbiotes weaknesses are sound waves
and fire which is adapted from the
comics it was actually sonic energy from
church bells that detached this Sabula
from Peter Parker oh not to pry but
Venom's earlier reaction the MRI was a
little weird considering MRIs don't use
sound waves they technically use radio
waves and electromagnetism just put it
out there anyway we come to this swatch
shootout during which if you listen
closely you can hear one of the officers
led out to a Wilhelm scream and brings
Eddie back to her new boyfriend Dan's
medical lab where she uses a high sound
frequency to force idiot off him and it
later reattaches to that dog that we saw
earlier which could be a nod to the
instances when venom binds to a dog in
the comics but I think there's a deeper
reference here earlier you may have
heard this dog's name Gemini which you
may know as a constellation and a sign
of a Zodiac Gemini actually refers to
the half twins castor and Pollux from
Greek mythology
when castor died Pollux shared his
immortality with his twin to keep the
two of them together and I think there's
definitely a parallel between their
shared existence and the relationship
between Eddie and venom two losers are
just need each other to survive
Drake tries to kill Eddie but he gets
rescued by Anne now herself binded a
venom now this is a nod to Steven him
that's when venom binds to an in the
comics and it causes her to lash out so
violently that Anne later actually takes
her own life at a guilt where is
Michelle Williams like everyone else in
this movie was just like oh I bit
someone's head off okay moving on that
brings us to Eddie and Venom's final
fight with Drake and riot now as I said
before riot is one of the five light
foundation offspring from the comics
though here venom describes him as a
team leader suggesting that on their
home planet
riot holds a higher rank in their race
which would explain why he could
shape-shift into more specific weapons
the concept designer said that he
imagined riot was the shattered mirror
image of the protagonist with sharper
angles and longer claws similar to
obsidian knives during this fight he
made noise riot whipping Venom's face
off that's actually a homage the cover
of the comic
carnage unleashed number three a defeats
Drake and riot saves the day he checks
him with an and he promises a more
disciplined career in journalism
starting off with a career with a figure
whom we later learned the post-credits
scene is cletus kasady a serial killer
who becomes carnage we get one last
Marvel wink a cameo from mr. Stanley
walking his dog I'll be referring to
Eddie and Ann or Eddie and venom now
look I know it's a little weird to see
Stanley considering this isn't the MCU
but remember venom is still a Marvel
Comics property and before the MCU even
existed
Stan would show up all the time in the
x-men movies and the Tobey Maguire and
Andrew Garfield spider-man movies bunch
of other stuff he's a massive
elucidation that belongs to everyone my
question for you is which direction
would you rather see this venom
franchise going a broader and more fans
service si directions so that venom and
spider-man could share the screen or a
darker and more violent direction so
that venom and carnage could lead in a
movie together comment down below with
your thoughts and thanks to our sponsors
Skillshare for helping us make this
video Skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes in
design business technology and more it's
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to high-quality classes on must
know topics so you can improve your
skills unlock new opportunities do the
work you love as you've probably noticed
I like going really deep into the craft
of these films that we talk about and
learning more about film editing has
really helped my own career as a
screenwriter in a filmmaker so
personally I got a lot out of Jordy
Vanna puts video editing with Adobe
Premiere Pro 2018 for beginners he's
just really great with all the tips in
the insight I highly recommend it also
folks skill sure is a lot more
affordable than most learning platforms
out there an annual subscription is less
than ten dollars a month and we're gonna
even do a special offer for you guys the
first 500 people to sign up with the
link in the description below will get
their first two months for free just go
to SKS h / new rockstars 7 or click on
the link in the description and don't
forget to follow me on twitter and
instagram at 80 Bahts subscribe to new
rock stars for these in-depth breakdowns
for all the stuff you love and lots of
random punch ends so thanks for watching
now - closed
[Music]